and on the mound today
for your detroit tigers yeah matt
manning
in his last starting six sentence three
runs given up against the baltimore
oreos i think we're numb to it right we
just
he's done it so often this year there's
a drive out to center field in right
center is where victor reyes picks it up
it is bright and glary this afternoon in
detroit and there's one gun to start the
game jose quintana on the mound for the
angels veteran 32 year old making his
23rd appearance
is today
the day
cabrera has gaudy numbers against
quintana the o2
line drive right up the middle base hit
and an rbi single from miguel cabrera he
gets closer to 3 000 now 47 hits away
and he's given the tigers the lead the
2-1 a chopper to second fletcher has to
wait for a sunday hop the run scores
candelario's in two-nothing tigers on
the bounce out by daz cameron
certainly not what he or the club had in
mind when he came aboard as a free agent
what a play by iglesias
preventing any further damage on a very
hard hit baseball two in the tigers half
of the first however
on to the second this afternoon in
motown two-nothing detroit
that's how they're starting to kind of
go out there and make sure he's a little
bit more violent by showing that on
first line
there's a drive out to right field off
the top of the wall off the bat of
brandon marsh adele never broke stride
he's streaking toward the plate he'll
score without a throw
into third is marsh and the angels are
on the board on a ball that just missed
getting out of here
and stassey bounces a ball to shortstop
that's gonna bring in a run great great
read by brandon marsh on contact how
quick both those runners adele marsh
flying around the bases tying the game
up here first start in the series for
zach short and zach's been kind of going
through it from an offensive standpoint
drives one deep left field maybe that'll
break him out of it
glad to see this young man get rewarded
for all the hard work seen him out early
every single day working on that swing
trying to work down and through the
baseball how about this swing jonathan
scope scored the game's first run in the
first
drives one to left center field
marsh coming hard and he
lets it drop in front the bases are
loaded and jose quintana will
unfortunately go just an inning and a
third this afternoon
candelaria whips on the right
that's in front of adele
garno scores
tigers add their lead it's now 4-2 and
the bases remain loaded for miguel
cabrera
so easy to say just be yourself just
play
[Applause]
grossman scores
scope is home
candelario rounds and burns for home a
bases clearing double for miguel cabrera
and as much as we all want to see the
500 home run we talk about the greatness
of miguel cabrera in the batter's box
hitting to the situation every day is
something you just go wow
that's just not real
over the shift into right field and
ohtani's got a base hit to lead off the
third
95 mile an hour fastball he turns on and
lines it for a base hit
and what he meant to the city of detroit
reyes starts the tigers third with a
base hit to right he'll dig for two
on his way and he's in there with a
first slide
aggressiveness pays off in detroit
when you're not at your best
grossman
finds a hole on the right side second
hit of the day for robbie grossman
and he'll dig for second and he's in
there
ohtani strike zone in joe madden's words
as organized as anybody's and you got
fletcher waiting on deck
yeah that just got out of his hands
weird slipped and that was trying to be
a curveball
that was another change up he went four
straight changeups
to ohtani
one one line to right
reyes is there and manning leaves him
loaded miguel cabrera back second in the
fourth he's already had a huge day right
you got people bungee jumping jumping on
the plane fly ball deep left center
field that ball's hammered and that ball
is
gone he's reached double digits and
homers the tigers extend their lead to
six and here's miguel cabrera here's the
3-1
chops it to third
gosling
and there's the first out in the tigers
fourth
weights on the 2-2
and here comes
fly ball deep left field that goes
justin upton that ball's gone
willy castro with his second homer in
his many days and the tigers add on
another
they were playing such good baseball all
the way up to that all-star break now
all of a sudden slowing down and the
other teams have picked it up
first pitch to uh upton the umpire
called it a foul ball the bat hit the
glove yeah he's saying it fouled off the
bat instead of strike that should be
catchers interference and he will get
first aj hints just got tossed it was
catcher's interference and your side is
up by seven runs i don't know what's
going on there's something else going on
between these two guys never let off the
gas here's the payoff
fairball
by a diving phil gosling that's an rbi
double for jonathan scope the tigers
have reached double figures
i heard the kind of predictable moaning
about the home run derby
and the toll on the body he beats that
out
another infield knock for ohtani
oh once i got by holland and scopes got
to go get it was like no chance
back to jimenez skate save and a beauty
it scores a run
right off the shoe
and it's an rbi infield single for phil
gosling yeah phil's got to feel good
about that off the off the bat it may
end up being a double play ball ends up
being an rbi single
and another easy take a four pitch walk
with the bases loaded in rbi for jared
three balls and a strike to upton
missed ball four back to back bases
loaded walks joe jimenez felt like he
was getting squeezed a little bit so he
has a few words for quinn wolcott and
they just tossed him
fastball that's bounced to shortstop
short to castro the one hop throw isn't
in time adele beats it out another run
scores brandon marsh will be the ninth
angel to hit in the inning marsh sends
it to center field and that's going to
get over cameron
walsh scores easily here comes adele
brandon marsha's big day continues and
the angels are somehow
right back in this game
the payoff
to third base bobbled by gosling and he
dropped it
he's aboard to lead off the six fletcher
waiting next one out bases empty 10 to
eight detroit
and there's ball four not even close
another walk
four times on base
up the next three balls in his strike to
walsh
that's into left center field
that's going to bring around ohtani to
make it a one-run game
he's going to have six played
appearances today here's a 3-1 home to
stassi swing and a drive into left field
that one's going to chance it's going to
go
homer for stassi and the halos have come
all the way back
santa maria
nine unanswered runs
to grab their first lead of the day
[Applause]
gave him another strike pretty good
strike on the inside corner of fly ball
into center
iglesias will tag he'll score
they choose to pitch to ohtani kind of
the sac fly to make it a two run game
[Applause]
broken bat just sawed him off
three hopper to fletcher
and the tigers go one two three for the
second straight inning and the second
time today phil's got hits in each of
his last two played appearances
there's a ball hit well out to left
field grossman will watch this one go
wow
finish to the day for gosling 13 to 10
angels
one two
and a historic comeback on the road for
the angels is sealed up